antoinat bonjour alors l'union
européenne par la voix de son haut
représentant a une fois de plus parler
de tentative de meurtre et d'utilisation
d'armes chimiques contre alexeï navalni
l'union européenne continue de mettre la
pression sur moscou sur la russie pour
qu'elle fournisse des explications des
clarifications sur cette affaire navalni
mais pour le kremlin impossible de
démarrer une enquête sans les documents
qu'elles demandent depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines à la partie allemande
et cette partie allemande qui refuse
toujours de les transmettre à moscou un
manque de coopération que déplore le
porte-parole du kremlin écoutait les
médecins russes ont suggéré un échange
d'échantillons biologiques ont suggéré
de mener un nouvel examen conjoint
tout cela a été proposé malheureusement
nous n'avons pas reçu de réponse à ce
sujet c'est ça le problème
nous ne tirons pas de conclusions
hâtives quant à l'impact de cette
situation sur nos relations avec un
certain nombre de pays européens
nous exprimons tout simplement notre
profonde incompréhension face à ce qui
se passe nous confirmons notre volonté
et notre intention de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé
alors on parle dans cette affaire du
novice choc sept agents neurotoxiques
développer du temps de l'urss n'est plus
tôt dans la journée le patron des
renseignements extrait extérieur russe a
assuré que tous les stocks de ce produit
avait bien été détruit conformément au
protocole de l'eau eyath et
l'organisation pour l'interdiction des
armes chimiques tandis que du côté d'
alexeï navalni vous l'avez dit son état
de santé s'améliore il a pu passer toute
une journée sans sans l'aide d'un sens
assistance respiratoire et peut même
temporairement quitté son lit d'hôpital
il est en tout cas de retour sur les
réseaux sociaux et a fait savoir qu'il a
fait part de sa volonté de sa
détermination à revenir en russie vit
dès que son état de santé le permettra
antonin clair merci à pour toutes ces
précisions